[Musique]
mais
une france pour rebâtir le monde
c'est ce qui est écrit sur votre affiche
mais que voulez vous dire par là et bien
en écrivant cette phrase j'ai pensé un
discours du général de gaulle prononcé à
alger en 1943 je crois à l'alliance
française de goldie la france est grande
s'il d'exemplaires bien entendu il pense
à la france libre exemplaires pour les
autres elle combat est au premier rang
du combat pour la justice mais vous être
grande
elle doit aussi être terre d'accueil
elle doit aussi accueillir en elle-même
les influences les idées de l'extérieur
et c'est une france creuser une france
catalyseurs se définit ainsi une france
pour rebâtir le monde différente d'une
france
il ne veut pas rebâtir le monde et
l'autre partie et d'une france frileuse
et égoïste
au moins cette france qui rebâtit le
monde c'est dans la période récente
c'est celle de pasto rien c'est celle
des amis de louis pasteur c'est la
france de calmette c'est la france d'
alexandre yersin
c'est la france d'autant goût le médecin
ou d'un groupe de chercheurs ou qui
bâtirent la santé publique donnée la
santé publique dans les pays tropicaux
était liée à l'idée de bâtir le paysage
de pâtir l'économie peut santé et
économie était une seule et même
conception cela pour moi une france qui
bâtit le monde alors on a mis aussi sur
cette affiche
sully colbert jaurès de gaulle et
certains disent vous confondez tout
qu'est ce que c'est que cette histoire
là ce sont des gens d'opinions
différents il est vrai sont des gens qui
prient 1 1 ont des opinions différentes
bien d'époque différents mais ils ont en
commun une chose être bâtisseur de
nation
ce sont des gens qui ont pensé à la
france comme un pays où chaque être
humain veut développer ses pouvoirs
créateurs développer sa capacité de
connaître de comprendre là
à venir dans les affaires publiques et
doit aider dans les autres pays les
autres à faire la même chose ça c'est
une france où bâtir le monde c'est la
france ce nouveau plan marshall
je préconise à la fois vers l'est et
vers le sud alors qu'est l'europe
voulez vous construire vient
certainement pas l'europe de maastricht
car elle se détruit elle même il ya cinq
critères de cette autorité ait pas trois
comme on dit souvent et ses cinq
critères d'austérité sont inapplicables
un seul pays aujourd'hui les remplit est
pas tout à fait un piqué d'une sorte de
grandes banques et le luxembourg le pays
ne parviennent pas à les remplir
pourquoi parce que y aller les accepter
c'est à s'appliquer à soi-même une telle
dose d'austérité ont détruit la
substance la texture des pays alors
certains des doublons peut tricher on
peut feindre on peut dire on les
applique sans les appliquer moi je suis
tout à fait contre cette hypocrisie et
je pense que elle n'a pas lieu d'être
faut faire une autre robe la vraie
europe celle d'un plan marshall d'un
vrai plan marshall orientée vers les
pays de l'est vers l'ensemble ghazi et
vers le sud dans l'ensemble afrique qui
soit une europe
opposée à celle de la rente financière à
laquelle consent au contraire l'europe
de maastricht alors cette nouvelle
europe cette europe du plan marshall est
bien pour la faire il faut que l'état
reprenne en main
l'émission de crédits et de monnaie et
ce faire il faut abolir l'autonomie la
banque de france par exemple dans notre
pays il faut aussi recréer une politique
de planification de planification
indicative mais qui soit une ardente
obligation comme dans les années 60
alors me dire oui mais vous pensez que
vous faire une europe allemande et
l'allemagne n'acceptera pas cela parce
que l'allemagne tient sa bundesbank plus
que tout mais je pense qu'aujourd'hui ce
n'est plus vrai ce n'est plus vrai parce
que en allemagne on commence à avoir
peur de ce qui se passe dans les pays de
l'est et on voit que ces pays de l'est
piller plus de 40 milliards de dollars
l'année dernière 30 milliards de dollars
auparavant
70 milliards de dollars sont sortis des
pays de l'est ce qui ont été
littéralement pillé encore une fois et
ces pays s'affaiblissent en particulier
la russie et en russie un mouvement de
rejet de cet ordre financier cette
politique financière
tu peut tourner très mal qui peut
tourner un état agressif un pinot cetin
maurus un régime à la pinochet en russie
donc comment échapper à cela
l'allemagne doit le savoir
lien comme l'ont dit certains sociaux
démocrates allemands c'est un plan
marshall il avis les pays de l'est ou
bien c'est la continuation de l'ordre
monétariste l'ordre financier auquel
participe la bundesbank et alors on crée
les conditions d'une crise très grave en
europe
donc je crois que les dirigeants
allemands auront peut-être le sentiment
ou pour s'en sortir il faut faire ce
plan marshall et alors nous autres et
les allemands devront le faire ensemble
car la france veut pas le faire seul et
si la france faisait seul se
condamnerait à une sorte d'isolement qui
ne peut pas être le fondement d'une
politique donc il faut que la france
pour vaincre les autres développe chez
les autres la même lucidité que chez
elle si nouveau président de la
république est lucide
y at il vraiment une nouvelle entente
cordiale avec l'angleterre
eh bien oui mais je dirais plutôt avec
londres la cité de londres qui est autre
chose que l'angleterre c'est plutôt avec
ses intérêts financiers qui constituent
la cité de londres qui lie à cette
entente cordier de la france pourquoi
est ce que la france a accepté
les dirigeants français ont accepté la
direction du trésor la banque de france
ont accepté un an monétariste qui
définit à londres c'est la tribune de
l'économie qui le dit ce n'est pas moi
tribune de l'économie du 7 novembre 1994
tous les chemins de la finance même à
londres kate à londres il y à la
première place mondiale pour les changes
de devises
la première on les marchés des actions
étrangères la première pour les
obligations
donc c'est la quête un pouvoir ce
pouvoir c'est celui qui gère le système
actuel de spéculation insensé on s'est
parlé à plusieurs reprises sur les
produits dérivés sur les taux d'intérêt
sur le trafic de drogue sur l'immobilier
c'est là que le centre se trouve et
qu'une conception du monde dans laquelle
on pense profits financiers c'est à dire
acheter bon marché revendre cher et
avoir le maximum d'argent dans le temps
le plus court possible
c'est là que cette conception ce trou
d'un autre celle de l'europe la
croissance et le développement celle de
l'économie physique productive et au
contraire celle l'accumulation de
capacité de produire grâce un socle à
une base infrastructures de pont de porc
de routes de voies ferrées à grande
vitesse qui permettent de tracer la
piste je dirais du décollage comme quand
un avion de décoller il faut tracer
d'avoir une piste et cette piste c'est
l'infrastructure
voilà ce qu'il faut faire
alors la france au lieu de cela à une
politique de compromission aujourd'hui
avec londres tantôt elle essaye
d'équilibrer ce qu'elle fait avec
l'allemagne parce qu'elle entend faire
avec londres tantôt elle va plus loin et
se rapproche de londres notamment en
matière militaire
tout cela est extrêmement dangereux et
avec moi il n'y aura certainement pas
d'entente cordiale avec la city avec
londres quelle est votre politique pour
le proche orient
et bien c'est là aussi la paix par le
développement économique mutuelle
connaît les gens de gaza qui ont un très
faible niveau de vie est bien la paix
pour eux doit être un meilleur sort
c'est la voirie c'est le tout à l'égout
c'est une infrastructure urbaine qui
sait les deux questions c'est tout ce
qui permet d'avoir l'espérance eh bien
on la donne pas on n'est pas en train de
la leur donner on a promis 750 millions
$ l'an dernier pour les territoires qu
on appelle les territoires et ils n'ont
reçu que 250 millions de dollars avec ça
on ne peut pas faire la paix et je crois
que la france
mind et aussi les états unis bien sûr ne
font pas ce qu'ils doivent pour assurer
cette paix moi j'ai beaucoup plus de
respect aux as being perez pour arafat
donc tenter cette paix que les
dirigeants actuels des pays occidentaux
je pense que cet effort doit être fait
au aider ces gens qui sont parmi ceux
que j'admire le plus aujourd'hui sur la
scène politique officielle mondiale en
outre il faut ce que shimon peres a
toujours voulu et que moi même et
discuter avec certains israéliens que ni
dans la roush également à discuter
depuis longtemps avec des israéliens des
irakiens et également des égyptiens il
faut une politique de paix par le
développement mutuel dans cette région
cela veut dire à terme comme allonge
l'eau amener l'eau et shimon pérès à
cette conception de l'eau par le
nucléaire par des centrales est salement
utilisant éventuellement l'énergie
nucléaire c'est également l'eau pour le
désert donc faire reverdir le désert et
c'est aussi tracé infrastructures artère
de vie autour du canal qui va de la
méditerranée à la mer morte et de
l'autre canal qui va de la mer morte à
la mer rouge
voilà ce qui doit permettre à terme ce
développement de toute la région et
c'est dans ce développement et l'avenir
et c'est pour cela nous devons
travailler un peu plus en europe
peut-on faire pour l'amener chez
et bien soutenir ceux qui veulent la
paix et pas ceux qui veulent la guerre
nous devons faire tous les efforts que
nous pouvons en français pour venir à
l'aide de ce qui rend ma sainte egidio
ont tenté de jeter les bases d'une paix
par l'intérêt mutuel c'est à dire les
républicains les démocrates en algérie
les vrais et les patriots islamistes
cela forme un groupe qui pour moi est la
chance d'avenir dans le pays l'asean il
n'a pas d'autres donc il faut cesser de
livrer des armes à la direction actuelle
de l'algérie d'une direction militaire
corrompu qui à mon avis est pour le pays
un facteur de guerre aujourd'hui il faut
pas soutenir ces gens là simplement faut
aussi dénoncer
de l'autre côté ce que sont certains
milieux du fils et le gia c'est à dire
des terroristes ils ne pratiquent pas
l'islam qui sont sorte de groupe des
voiliers de gens sous influences de
toutes sortes d'agents de renseignements
il faut être ferme durr avec ces gens là
mais il faut aussi une porte de sortie
économique nous devons plus du tout
faire la politique du fonds monétaire
internationale là bas
au contraire il faut que l'algérie soit
le coeur dans le maghreb de la branche
sud du plan marshall c'est à dire d'une
politique de développement de l'ensemble
de la région est là aussi
collomb proche orient il faut faire
reverdir le désert enfin il ya quelque
chose qui me paraît fondamental sur le
plan de la culture c'est d'encourager ou
de revenir à ceux qui ont mené dans
l'histoire de l'algérie une réflexion
autour la conciliation entre islam et
république s'agit essentiellement
d'abdelkader et de faire à ta basse ou
haute et maroc de benchmark là ces gens
là doivent être relu leurs idées doivent
être revécu je pense qu'un algérie
obscurément peut-être sans toujours le
savoir la majorité de pays veut aller
dans cette direction
tout non là pensez vous qu'il faille
redéfinir la politique africaine de la
france où est certainement est
totalement ne faut plus de ses clientes
et
m'identifie au nom de charles pasqua il
faut une autre politique qui soit une
politique de développement de ces pays
pas de constitution de groupes de réseau
il faut autre chose pour moi c'est le
plan marshall
le nouveau plan marshall vis-à-vis de
ces pays et ces désenclaver c'est à dire
faire que des régions d'afrique qui
aujourd'hui ne communique pas puissent
communiquer entre elles pour se vendre
des produits aujourd'hui par exemple et
des gens qui produisent des biens
alimentaires et à 400 km et des gens qui
en ont besoin mais n'arrivent pas
communiqué la vente ne se fait pas pour
aller acheter ailleurs il faut changer
cela
il faut aussi prévoir des réseaux à la
fois qu'ils vont à l'intérieur mais
également un terreau côtier jusqu'à
maintenant les chemins de fer ont été
faits pour piller les ressources il faut
faire des chemins de fer vous développez
l'intérieur du pays c'est différent
alors me direz vous rêvez c'est une
utopie bien pas du tout à la fin du 19e
siècle
gabriel hanot tôt c'était un homme qui
avait travaillé avec gambetta dans la
république
gabriel un taux avec tout un plan cela
et je veux vous lire ce qu'il disait et
cette époque là en afrique dit il ils
font un chemin de fer qui soit le
véritable conquérant et il envisageait
trois tracé d'une ligne transsaharienne
et cette époque là à l'est une liaison
bizerte brazzaville par beaugrard à
ghadamès rate bel mal lac tchad tsonga
et le congo et le projet de monsieur
bonnart l'ingénieur au centre il y avait
une liaison prévue biskra ouargla astute
lac tchad et j'en reparlerai rejoignant
la précédente c'est le projet monsieur
le rolland il y avait enfin à l'ouest un
tracé sud oranais tombouctou visant à
unir le sénégal et l'algérie dont nous
parlions tout à l'heure et hanotaux dit
c'est la conception d'un profit qui est
un profit infrastructure qui permet le
décollage est pas celle du profit butin
anglaise pas du profit pillages alors
c'est cela qu'il faut et je crois que
symboliquement ya un projet qu'on doit
faire très vite
c'est celui de la revitalisation du lac
tchad ce lac faisait environ avant les
années 70 vingt mille kilomètres carrés
il est descendu jusqu'à 2000 km qu'a
donc faut ramener l'eau et une politique
d'urgence y est de sauver et nourrir les
populations subissent la sécheresse
on le voit dans tout ce qui est dit donc
les rapports qui sont faits sur cette
région là sur le tchad
il ya ensuite leur donner de l'eau faire
des barrages par exemple un avant de
bangui pour que le tchad soit
revitaliser le lac
ensuite il faut recréer un réseau
hydrographique c'est-à-dire refaire que
l'eau cette fois ci de manière organisée
par viennent là bas et qu'on exploite là
où l'eau arrive c'est à dire qu'on fasse
une véritable politique de paul bert
isation autour du lac
c'était très vif et on évite ainsi
l'ensablement
enfin là bas il faut redonner à
l'ensemble une vision de croissance une
vision de développement c'est à dire que
lac tchad soit un peu un foyer qui
rayonnent autour ou le développement ça
c'est le type de politique qu'il nous
faut absolument aujourd'hui en afrique
et cela change complètement la logique
actuelle parce que il ne s'agit pas être
d'une logique soit de pillage grandes
exploitations
mais il s'agit d'une logique dans
laquelle les habitants de la région
participent aux travaux participent au
développement et ainsi devienne partie
prenante et cela c'est après base de la
démocratie en afrique
la vraie base démocratie par le
développement pourquoi tant parler de
politique étrangère dans une campagne
électorale française parce que politique
intérieure et politique extérieure
doivent être cohérentes comme de gaulle
le savait et le voulait si on ne le fait
pas on se condamne à la puissance voit
pire encore comme en bosnie
[Musique]